if you've listened to this show
regularly over the past few months you
know that I've done a couple of
monologues on the aviation industry the
frequency of near disasters in the sky
has increased dramatically in recent
years and as I've noted the increase
began around the same time that the
Obama Administration began a concerted
effort to diversify the FAA including
air traffic control now according to a
NASA database which uh tracks
self-reported data from Pilots we now
average roughly five near misses per
week more than double the number from a
decade ago and that's not even getting
into the obvious maintenance issues that
have been you know popping up including
doors and wheels that have been flying
off of planes mid-flight now given how
terrible all this looks from the outside
I wanted to get a better idea of what's
Happening internally at the FAA and
major airlines in this country you we
hear a lot about Dei in the abstract
sense but when we R we rarely get a
glimpse of what it looks like in
practice we don't often hear firsthand
testimonials from people affected by Dei
because they're worried about you know
protecting their careers so they don't
talk about it they know if they speak
out they'll face termination they'll
probably be blackballed from the
industry forever but with social media
some level of anonymity is possible so
to take a closer look at how far this
DEA Dei rot has spread I tweeted this if
you're an airline pilot and have
firsthand knowledge about the Dei agenda
being forced into your profession send
me a DM and tell me about your
experiences curious yet terrified to see
how bad it is at this point now I sent
that out a couple weeks ago to say that
my inbox was completely flooded would be
an understatement I received too many
DMS to count from pilots and other
Professionals in the aviation industry
uh virtually every message that I read
told me the same thing that the ideology
of diversity equity and inclusion is the
top priority in their workplaces it goes
without saying but this is an industry
where one mistake can kill hundreds or
even thousands of people this is not
comparable to Dei departments and
universities or Corporate America as
destructive and wasteful as those those
departments are Dei in the aviation
industry could lead to a catastrophic
disaster master and that's why even
though it was a risk several of these
sources provided me identifying
information to validate their identities
along with permission to post some of
the internal documents and footage that
they obtained and shared with me these
people knew that they might lose their
jobs but they decided to you know that
the getting the word out was more
important yesterday I posted some of
this material on uh my Twitter feed they
they reveal that at the very highest
levels of the FAA there's an effort
underway to reduce the number of white
men who work in the aviation industry
this is a priority of the FAA in April
of 2022 the faa's acting Deputy Chief
Operating Officer a woman named Angela
Mulla led a meeting with the faa's
flight Operations Division this division
is responsible for all aspects of
Aviation operations including overseeing
Airline maintenance so it's pretty
important division but Mulla did not
spend the call talking about ways to
make sure that airplane doors don't fly
off mid-flight she didn't say a word
about the importance of keeping the
wheels attached to jetliners as they're
taking off instead maalla talked
extensively about Dei as you'll see uh
she was prompted to do so by a man named
will Riggins who's the faa's vice
president of flight program operations
and if that name does sound familiar to
you at all it's probably because Riggins
is the same guy who conspired to find
ways to hide be Pete Budaj jig's uh
spending on government aircraft so we've
we've seen him in the news before uh for
uh all the wrong reasons and then this
we know is means that this is a
completely corrupt group of bureaucrats
who have come around and assembled here
to talk about the problems of white men
in aviation and uh here's a little bit
of that watch and and we're looking at
that but we're also looking at really a
need across the agency to recruit and
retain a diverse uh population of folks
and as you mentioned earlier you know
how much that adds to to the process um
what do you think are some of the key
points that we need to remember uh as we
as we embark on this challenge going
forward oh that oh that's that's a
pretty good um a pretty good question I
think one of one of the things we need
to now is that everyone else is
embarking on the same thing right just
across the system so competition is
going to be um competition is going to
be it's just going to be really heavy
right so a I think we um we need to know
that I think it's going to take some um
some creativity you heard Tim say he and
I had talked about and we're going to
you all is you know are there
opportunities for any Partnerships um
with uh universities or trade schools
that specialize um we kind of talk about
from you know rant to cockpit is there
some things that we would want to look
at um there so will rigin says we're
looking at a need across the agency to
recruit and retain a diverse population
of folks and in response Mulla talks
about the arms race of Dei that's
occurring in the industry she mentions
Partnerships with universities and then
she says that the FAA wants to look at
something called ramp to cockpit now
let's think about both of these things
for a minute when she's talking about
Partnerships with universities in the
name of diversifying Aviation Mulla is
referring to relationships that Airlines
have established with historically black
colleges and universities and for
example United Airlines has allied with
um allied with uh Elizabeth City State
University the airline describes this as
a quote partnership that seeks to not
only train future Pilots but also bring
more women and people of color into the
ranks of commercial aviation in case
it's not obvious Elizabeth City State
University is not a hot bed of
engineering or Aviation talent in fact
it's not a hot B of any kind of skill
whatsoever the average SAT score at the
school is 960 out of 1,600 which is one
of the lowest scores you'll find
anywhere in the country as an average
score for a university only reason for
Partnerships like this is because of the
the racial makeup of Elizabeth City
State University which is overwhelmingly
black this is the kind of part parip
that based on this video senior FAA
officials want to see more of they want
to partner with the worst most mediocre
least impressive universities in the
country they're not interested in seeing
the best pilots in the cockpit they're
interested in seeing more black pilots
and quote unquote diverse pilots in the
cockpit that also could explain why
Mulla is promoting something called ramp
to cockpit in that footage when she says
ramp she's referring to ramp agents who
are responsible for loading and
unloading baggages uh uh baggage on on
on airplanes so so evidently the FAA
believes that these employees deserve
some sort of specialized program to
encourage them to become Pilots but
nowhere in this footage does McCulla
explain why this makes any sense
whatsoever it does not follow okay this
doesn't follow in any way the job of a
baggage handler is completely different
from the job of an airline pilot they
are totally different there are
precisely zero transferable skills or
even interests
the the only thing that makes them the
same is that you're both working around
a
plane just because you have a job
working around a plane doesn't mean you
should be flying them this is like
having a janitor to surgeon pipeline at
a hospital or setting up a program so
that the the window washer cleaning the
outside of the skyscraper can one day
become an architect designing
skyscrapers these two lines of work have
almost nothing to do with each other so
what's the point of this well a few
seconds later provides something of an
answer she tells the faa's senior
leadership in Flight operations that
their whole division is quote white male
dominated then she says that well that
should change and will Riggins rather
than reacting with surprise to this
suggestion of course agrees with her
watch we need to be willing to to have a
conversation about kind of what's
standing in our way from approaching
some of these things um um differently
than we have historically approached
them and just even the internal bias I
mean particular l in Flight Ops this
your whole program is very heavily Mal
dominated it just is and really it is
white male dominated if I mean let's
just say what it is and so let's be
willing that is today what it is and
then let's talk about what could the
future look like if if if you really had
this program that was representative of
the whole um country right of the whole
world and um sometimes those are Challen
Ching or you know difficult or I would
say people get a little bit
uncomfortable um um talking about that
and um like Hey we're not going to make
change unless we get a little bit
uncomfortable and let's be uncomfortable
together and let's do the right things
and support each other moving forward so
I don't know if you wanted all that but
you got it sir no Ang that's great
honestly um those those are some words
that that we really need to spend some
time I think kind of digging through and
and thinking
about now one thing you know that if if
you hear somebody on the left use the
phrase we need to have an uncomfortable
conversation you know that the dumbest
thing in the world is about to follow
from that whatever whatever comes next
is going to be the dumbest thing you've
ever heard that's the way it always
works and and of course there's no push
back from anybody in that clip as they
listen to this nobody says well wait a
minute why should baggage handlers
become pilots and what's wrong with
having a lot of white men in Flight
operations exactly what is the problem
what problem has been caused by the
disproportionate number of white men
what what issue are you trying to solve
lady they don't say that instead this
woman gets complimented for her
insights but of course not everybody on
that call was in agreement they didn't
want to speak up because they'd be fired
but they knew that this was going to
happen so one individual recorded the
meeting and this Source had seen several
white men get passed over for jobs
because of their skin color and he or
she heard these kinds of remarks all the
time at the F FAA and that's why they
saved it and uh save the video and
that's why we have it now if you're
getting ready to watch the big game this
weekend you need to check out bet online
bet online has the largest offering of
betting odds in the world you can bet on
virtually anything from how many total
passing yards Patrick Mahomes will get
uh will will get to whether Reba will
forget a word in the national anthem or
if you think Taylor Swift will make it
from Japan to cheer on Travis bet online
is the best online sports betting
platform they Pride themselves on their
higher than average betting limits of up
to $225,000 you can increase your
wagering amounts by by contacting their
player Services desk by phone or email
so don't be the odd man out when
everybody around you is talking about
their betting predictions on the biggest
sporting event of the year go to
betonline.ag to place your bets for the
big game this Sunday use promo code
Walsh for a 50% instant deposit bonus of
up to $1,000 that's
betonline.ag and use promo code Walsh
bet online the options are endless as of
this morning neither the FAA nor the
Secretary of Transportation uh Pete
Budaj have responded to this footage
that's because it reflects exactly what
they believe this is what they talk
about behind closed doors they want
fewer white people flying planes and
working in Flight operations including M
maintenance they want fewer white people
doing everything you know they want they
want more baggage handlers to become
pilots and they're not remotely
concerned about Professional Standards
or competence or safety that topic just
doesn't come up in their
discussions this is what Dei is all
about it's not limited to Pete Budaj
jig's agency in response to my post I
received several other tips from sources
outside of the FAA who say that they are
seeing similar policies all across the
aviation industry airlines are promoting
Dei just like the FAA is uh even when it
clearly endangers passengers so here's
another example One Source piloted at
Del Delta Airlines uh told me this quote
we recently had a transgender pilot
repeatedly received negative reviews
during his first year probationary
period from captains he flew with
regarding attitude CRM and judgment yet
the chief pilot officer office CPO was
unwilling to address the issue had this
not been a transgender pilot the
individual would likely not have
successfully completed their
probationary period coincidentally that
CPO has a management pilot on staff who
recently transitioned who was able to
weigh in on these
matters this is what the Airlines and
FAA will never admit publicly they'll
never admit that they're lowering
standards and endangering the public in
order to get more diverse pilots flying
planes and from an official standpoint
it's because they haven't they they
haven't passed a policy officially
saying the standards are being lowered
instead what happens in practice is
exactly what this pilot told me and what
I've in many other similar stories I've
I heard um that they they kind of
unofficially look the other way when
incompetent people who are in a
preferred
group um are are screwing up and that's
what's happening the source also sent
along this internal Delta Airlines
manual that designed to help Delta
Pilots quote transition into another
gender and here's what that looks like
um it reads helpful steps for
transitioning at Delta
and of course there's the the pilot with
the gay trans Pride flag or whatever uh
draped over his body like exactly what
you want to see right it goes without
saying that I mean this is incredibly
irresponsible for several reasons put
aside the fact that Delta is
discriminating against qualified pilots
on the basis of their skin color and
their gender and promoting incompetent
Pilots Instead This document shows that
Delta is also going out of their way to
recruit trans identifying Pilots people
who have extremely high rates of mental
illness and a propensity for suicide
remember these are these are people who
according to the trans activist
themselves are at risk of killing
themselves if they're misgendered or if
they don't receive all the affirmation
they feel they need I mean this this is
a this is a category of people with uh
suicidal audiation rates that are like
exponentially higher than the general
population and the FAA and Delta want
more of them flying commercial
aircraft in fact in private they're open
about the fact that they're willing to
endanger the public in order to hit
diversity goals recently on Twitter
somebody uh named Trace woodgrains has
been looking closely at FAA documents
that were unearth in a long-running
class action lawsuit filed against the
agency back during the Obama years and
he found proof that the agency does not
care if diversity quote unquote costs
people their lives like they they've put
it in writing in 2013 for example FAA
leaders reviewed this slide and the
slide reads key questions for leadership
what are the relative values of
diversity in the prediction of
performance SL outcomes there is a
trade-off between diversity adverse
impact and predicted job performance
outcomes how much of a change in job
performance is acceptable to achieve
diversity
goals so there it is as clear as
possibly could be like they are willing
to trade job job performance in order to
achieve diversity
goals and what does job performance mean
when you're an airline pilot if you
perform poorly in your job as an airline
pilot it means like 200 people
die now I can answer the question that
they've asked
rhetorically what kind of trade-off is
acceptable well no trade-off in job
performance is acceptable to achieve any
diversity goals in any industry
especially the airline
industry like the whole mission of the
FAA is supposed to be to to make sure
that people don't die on airplanes
really it should be summed up that way
but increasingly it's clear that that's
just not important to the FAA I didn't
mention this on Twitter but one of the
uh sources who dm' me uh sent me this
information as well uh this is another
DM I got quote I was unaware of this
until recently but the FAA has
authorized special issuance medical
certificates to individuals on ssris the
FAA and the airline pilot associ iation
are looking to broaden expand the SSRI
and mental health on ramps back to being
able to exercise a first class medical
certificate in other words the agency is
doing everything it can to ensure that
Pilots taking
anti-depressants can fly these are
pilots who are struggling with
depression and who need medical
assistance with their depression that
they can be flying people in the sky at
the same time the source says quote the
FAA just sent a letter requesting
congress not to raise the mandatory
retirement age from the current age of
65 and the fa primarily States safety as
a justification obviously there's zero
safety data that shows a switch is
flipped when you turn 65 and you're
somehow instantly less competent we all
know competent 70y olds and incompetent
50-year olds running around the point is
that the FAA and the pilots Association
are much more willing to go along with
the idea that ssris and transitioning
Pilots should be at the controls uh and
that's somehow more safe than somehow
someone who just woke up on their 65th
birthday so
these are the kinds of incoherent
medical standards we've come to expect
in the FAA a year ago for example the
FAA abruptly lowered its medical
certification guidelines for Pilots with
heart block and and this is a serious
condition it makes it harder for the
heart to pump blood effectively before
the change Pilots with first-degree
block had to provide medical
documentation proving they had quote no
evidence of structural function or
coronary heart
disease now many Pilots with first
degree block can fly without this
documentation there was a lot of
speculation that this was due to
complications of the co shot or that
this might implicate the safety of
passengers the FAA denied that but of
course we have no reason to believe
anything they say anymore this is what
we can expect from the federal
government at this point even on matters
of of life or death they have just no
credibility there are some more
documents I posted on Twitter along
these lines including some Insider
information on how the FAA Awards
contracts to various small businesses
they these small small businesses handle
important engineering and logistic tasks
for the agency but it turns out that
these contracts like everything else
these days often prioritize socially
disadvantaged businesses which according
to Federal Regulations typically means
that they aren't owned by white people
in the faa's East contract system these
disadvantaged businesses get first dibs
at contracts valued under $150,000 and
what this means is that the FAA has
adopted a gender and race-based spoil
system for pretty much everything at
every step whether you're a baggage
handler a pilot a contractor you will
get priority treatment if you look a
certain
way the only way to bring an end to this
madness is for more whistleblowers to do
what uh these whistleblowers did
yesterday and speak out about it record
the meetings where they tell you they
they don't want white people working for
them save the document showing they're
promoting incompetent Pilots because
they're
trans if we expose enough of this then
it might finally collapse the whole
scheme under the weight of its own
absurdity if we don't if we allow it to
Fester as everyone on that FAA video
conference did then before long as I've
been warning now for months a lot of
people are going to die as a
result thanks for checking out this
video if you'd like to listen to my full
podcast on the go you can check out the
Matt wall show on Apple podcast Spotify
or wherever you get your podcasts